this is one of the things that the
technology companies in general and
Facebook specifically has been concerned
about both on a monopoly side of things
and in the appropriate use of data so
the collection of data and the proper
use of data you know the conversation
started around how large they've gotten
how much reach they have and how many
have monthly average users they have but
really shifted around the election and
the use of Facebook to micro-target
voters and and and sort of point them in
a direction during the presidential
election so now we've got you know a
smoking gun and that then the latest
revelation and it's hard to know how bad
this gets so we're at the beginning
stages of finding out the FTC is looking
into this and certainly investigations
will we'll uncover more but right now
we're in that stage where investors are
going to shoot first and ask questions
later shoot first and ask questions
later I mean is this an existential
crisis for facebook well it's certainly
one of the more difficult things they've
faced you know when they when they first
came public that one of the things they
try to do is navigate the move from
desktop to mobile they successfully did
that one of the biggest challenges has
been to monetize that monthly average
user that that knowledge of that data
without becoming an annoyance
so it's annoying enough to be sort of
persuaded to buy a pair of Wellington's
or a proper jumper but to be
micro-targeted in terms of an election
and have your opinions sort of targeted
and and in that way is a severe invasion
of privacy and I think that's where the
excellence of crisis may be coming about
I think it's the the regulatory
oversight that Facebook has been able to
avoid throughout its history may be
coming to an end here pretty soon
well Kim let me bring you in what about
the implications for the rest of big
tech well I think if you have ordinary
folks as your product which Twitter snap
and Google certainly do you are probably
in the target if you are a company that
serves other companies and just helps
them do their regular course of business
I don't think you have much to fear
other than what you've always feared
which is having your customers data
escape the problem here is these social
media companies were more media than
tech and I don't think that they ever
thought would find out that they
they track us that narrowly and or
profoundly let's put it that way
and you know sometimes people get
creeped out and I know this is a real
concept but they may stop using your
product if that happens and then the
advertisers go away because they're only
here trying to get our attention and
paying to do so
so can what sort of things are investors
looking to see from Facebook now how
should it be responding to these
accusations well would really like to
see how much money it gets from these
non straightforward arrangements that it
has you know as the other guests said
we're pretty much used to being served
up promoted articles or you know
straightforward advertising like we've
come become used to with TV you know in
exchange for getting free TV or almost
free TV you have to sit through washing
machine commercials and dog food
commercials and and that sort of thing
but it's you know the fact that the
cable companies know exactly minute by
minute what you're watching and by the
way they sell that data to people who
are willing to buy it I'm not sure
everybody knows that and once that comes
out I think we're gonna have a real
discussion on whose data it is and why
anybody should want that data I mean art
is there a danger that Facebook itself
over reacts to this with data protection
measures that starting to eating into
its own profitability yeah that's the
real the you know the the real fear here
is what is the reaction and how much do
you change don't understand Facebook was
going through a change in the way they
presented their their timelines in there
and there's the formats I think that was
one you know initial reaction to some of
the pushback and and the the beginning
of the election cycle I think now are
you gonna make Facebook look like
something that's just not usable and
understanding that individuals have
options here there there are other
places to go in social media Facebook
used to be the only game their audience
has matured so they've lost some of the
Millennials and you know to other
formats and social media now how are
they going to retain that isn't and and
and you know
how quickly can they address this that's
one of the things we haven't heard yet
we haven't heard from leadership
leadership seems to be staying in the
background until they finish an internal
audit so they know the and can assess
the amount of the damage that's been
done here but one of the things we need
to hear pretty quickly is is from
management how they're addressing the
problems and how much that's can
adversely affect their business model
Kim let me ask you this there's a lot of
talk now about increased regulation
right across the sector but I mean
paradoxically high increased regulation
could actually benefit the incumbents
and make it harder for for newcomers
absolutely well first of all you may not
know this but all of the tech companies
whether or not they have or social media
or what I consider old tech you know
that serves businesses they've all
ramped up their spending on lobbyists so
I think everybody understands in Silicon
Valley that they could be regulated and
you're right if you know if the rules
have remained for your current business
it would be very difficult to be a new
business to get in the business of
selling data so you're right this could
all safai the leadership right now but
it all hinges on and I think we really
have some control over this is what kind
of information we're willing to give out
and where we're willing to participate
we could go back to the bad old days and
just email our photographs to one
another or somebody could come up with
another platform that has for whatever
reason doesn't sell ad space so you know
if there still is a lot out there and
the game's not over all right very brief
last question to both of you Facebook's
market value has fallen by about 63
billion dollars since last Friday in a
word both of you have the has a sell-off
been overdone
what do you think I don't think we've
priced in a worst-case scenario here so
it's it's it's on a need-to-know basis
and going forward to see what kind of
reaction management has here but we
certainly haven't priced in worst case
scenario yet all right what do you think
in well mercifully we're not big holders
this is not one of our core positions
but that aside you know I think it is up
to management and how they're going to
you know remediate this problem and
assure their users both the advertisers
and the normal people of the behavior
that they're going to you know go have
going forward so it's all up to the
company